Where you are going is
just as important as how
you plan to get there.
As we look forward
to new frontiers
here on Earth and beyond,
places where resources may be
scarce or non-existent, we
need to look for new ways
to carry ourselves
beyond the horizon, ways
like sailing on currents
of air, drawing energy
from the rays of the sun.
BERTRAND PICCARD,
MD: Everything I
do is the example I
received from my grandfather
and my father.
My grandfather made the first
flight in the stratosphere.
Actually, he was the first man
to witness with his own eyes
the curvature of the Earth.
My father went to the bottom
of the Mariana Trench,
11 kilometers down, the
deepest spot in the ocean.
I thought it was
normal to explore.
And for a long time,
the exploration
was about discovering new
geographical territories.
And I believe that
now, exploration
has a role to play if we
want to make a better world.
ANDRE BORSCHBERG:
And 30 years ago, we
had this idea to fly around the
world without the dependence
on fossil energy.
They told us it was impossible.
So that was the starting point.
BERTRAND PICCARD,
MD: Solar Impulse
is a feat of exploration.
It's a scientific adventure.
The goal was to demonstrate
how you can use solar energy
to fly around the world.
ANDRE BORSCHBERG: It
was not possible to take
an existing airplane, and
to glue some solar cells.
It would never work.
So we had to rethink
this airplane
completely from scratch.
The conclusion was to make
an airplane the size of a 747
with the weight of a car--
the only airplane today
which can fly almost forever.
BERTRAND PICCARD, MD:
And these technologies
can be used everywhere,
not just in our airplane.
And this moment
of rupture, where
you left behind what you know,
and enter into the unknown--
it's the leap of faith.
In 2016, Solar Impulse
became the first aircraft
in aviation history
to circumnavigate
the globe with no fuel.
BERTRAND PICCARD, MD:
If you want exploration,
very often you need to
get out of the system,
because the system is paralyzed
by common assumptions.
It's not the people
selling candles
who invented the light bulb.
We succeeded to use solar
energy to fly around the world.
It's interesting to see the
difference between conquering
and exploring.
When you want to conquer,
it's to have more.
When you want to explore,
it's to know more.
The future will
be very different.
So you need an
explorer's mild if you
want to succeed in the future.